in this video you're going to learn how
to work with permutations combinations
factorials as well as how to calculate
probabilities what we're going to do is
we're going to go through the concepts
first here briefly and then we're going
to dive into 15 word problems story
problems so we can get some practice in
applying these Concepts so let's start
off with a basic example say for example
you have the letters h a and t spelling
the word hat and say we wanted to find
out how many different permutations are
there of the letters in the word hat now
when you think of the word permutations
permutations refers to like an ordering
so like how many different ways can we
order those letters all three of those
letters now let's just go ahead and do
it by hand here so we can see h a t we
could also write it as h t a we could do
a t h or a h t or what else t a h or t h
a and those are the only possibilities
so sometimes this is referred to as a
sample space basically showing you like
all the possible outcomes but these are
the permutations of the orderings
another way to do this you can do a tree
diagram you could say like when I
imagine if I put these three letters
into like a hat okay like this here's
our three letters on sheets of paper
let's just say h a and t and what we're
doing is we're going to reach into that
hat and we're going to pick out a letter
so for the first letter we could pick an
H an A or a t right but if we pick an h
and we set it aside
when we go to pick the next letter what
can we do well we could either pick an A
or a t Okay and then if we pick let's
say an h and an a there's only a t Left
Right whereas if we pick an h a t then
there's only going to be an a left and
the same thing over here we could do a t
or H or if we do a t then this would be
like an h and this would be like a t or
we could do a or H and then this could
be an H or an A and so basically if you
kind of think of this as like a root you
could either go down this root h a t or
h t a or ath and that's another way of
getting these uh permutations or
possible permutations another option is
to use what we call a factorial see that
exclamation point there that doesn't
mean like uh yay right it means you take
the number and you multiply down to one
so for example in this case we had three
letter h a and t so we'd say well
there's three possibilities for what we
can pick out for that first letter once
we pick out that first letter there's
two choices for the second letter that
we pick out and then lastly there's only
one letter for the final choice and so
this is really 3 times 2 times 1 which
is 6 or you can write this in a more
condensed fashion three factorial
and that represents three times two
times one so n factorial is when you're
trying to see how many different
ordering there are of all n items now
sometimes what happens is you only want
to maybe pick two of the items or one of
the items okay or like that so in that
case you would use this concept here or
the NPR what does that mean it means out
of n items how many ways are there of
picking R of those items where the order
is important we're also going to talk
about combinations okay combinations and
this is when the order is not important
but let's talk about the permutations
first so NPR let's say for example out
of the three letters here how many ways
are there to pick just two of the
letters where the order is important
well let's try to write it out again so
what we could do is we could say well
there could be a h and a or there could
be a and H
or so that's one possibility another
possibility we could do T and H
or we could do H and T
and we could do a and t or T and A and
so you can see here that this is there's
six different uh
possibilities of choosing two letters
out of three where the order is
important now we can use this formula
this is another way to do it you could
say n factorial so that's going to be so
we're doing three p two out of three
items we're picking two where the order
is important so that's going to be 3
factorial over three minus two which is
one factorial now remember we already
talked about how factorials you multiply
down to one so this is going to be 3
times 2 times 1 which is 6 all over one
factorial which is just one so you can
see there's six different possibilities
and these are the six that we just wrote
down here
now what happens if you're not concerned
with the order that's what a combination
is so if we said how many ways are there
to choose two letters out of three where
the order is not important what we would
have is h and a A and H those would be
like the same
like outcome it's the same two letters
so you'd only count that once T and H H
and T those are the same two letters
we'd only count that once a and t t and
a we'd only count that once because it's
the same two letters so what we could do
here we could say three C two okay three
combination two equals three factorial
over three minus two which is one
factorial
and then times R factorial which is 2
factorial now you might be saying you
know these formulas look very similar to
one another
the only difference is we're dividing by
this R factorial what that R factorial
is doing is it's dividing out the
multiplicities meaning that you're not
going to count h and a and a and H is
the same I mean as two different ones
you're going to count it as the same
outcome right so you don't want to
double count and so that's what we're
doing is we're basically saying H A and
H we don't want to double count that so
we're dividing by 2 factorial so if we
simplify this we get 3 times 2 times 1 1
factorial is one two factorial is 2
times 1. you can see these are canceling
and three divided by 1 is equal to 3 and
you can see we got three
outcomes here so one other thing that's
important to remember when you have this
n factorial one factorial we said is one
zero factorial you have to memorize this
one it's also equal to one so if you get
zero factorial just realize that's one
so let's dive into some of the word
problems and you'll get a better feel
for how to work with these permutations
combinations factorials and even
probability which we're going to talk
about in just a second
now when we talk about probability what
probability is it's the number of
successful outcomes or what you're
looking for what you want divided by the
total possible number of outcomes and
that's why we're talking about
permutations and combinations first
because that tells us the number that
we're dealing with the number of
successes or the number of total
possible outcomes but when you think of
probability it's written as a fraction
or a decimal unless they say what's the
percent chance that something could
happen but basically probability again
is just talking about the the number of
what you want divided by the total and
that's what our permutations are going
to give us our combinations are going to
give us our factorials are going to give
us so let's dive into some word problems
when you're doing these problems on your
homework or just trying to solve
problems on your own you may not have
problems that are exactly like these
problems these 15 that we're going to do
but you'll have ones that are similar so
if you understand these Concepts you can
apply them to additional problems that
you're working on so let's go through
this variety of problems so starting
with number one it says how many
distinguishable permutations are there
of the word mathematics so basically
again they're talking about permutations
that's saying how many ways are there of
ordering all these letters so that it
forms a new quote-unquote word well
there's a lot of letters here if we had
to write them out by hand we would grow
old and and die because it's going to
take a long time right
so an easy way of doing this is let's
count how many letters there are one two
three four five six seven eight nine ten
eleven so there's 11 factorial ways okay
remember we talked about n factorial
there's 11 factorial ways of ordering
all those letters but you see how
there's some repetitions we have two M's
so we're going to divide by two
factorial there's
two A's so we're going to divide by
another two factorial and there's two
T's so we're going to divide by another
two factorial now if there was three T's
we divide by 3 factorial or if there's
four r's let's say you divide by four
factorial and the reason is like two
factors two times one meaning there's
two different ways to take these M's and
like interchange them but it would form
the same word mathematics you wouldn't
even know that anything was different
about it so that's why it's saying uh
distinguishable I mean you can tell that
they're different
so what we're going to do now is we're
going to go to the calculator you should
have a factorial button if not you can
just do 11 times 10 times 9 all the way
down to 1. the factorial is probably
under a probability key that you have on
your calculator that's what mine's under
and then I'm going to divide by 2
factorial which is 2 times 1 2 times 1 2
times 1 which is 8. so I'm going to
divide 11 factorial by 8 not 8 factorial
but just the number eight and that's
coming out to
4989600 so basically almost 5 million
different ways of
ordering these letters such that it
forms a new quote unquote word okay
quite a few so number two now let's look
at this one it says if there are 20
people in a bike race how many ways are
there of awarding a first second and
third place metal assuming that there
are no ties
okay a little bit different problem here
so now what we're trying to do is figure
out out of 20 people
want to know how many ways there are of
picking three of those people to be the
first second and third place finisher
and oftentimes what you want to ask
yourself is the order important or is it
not important so if I change like person
a b and c c b and a is that result in a
different outcome well yes because in
that case they would be getting
different Metals gold silver bronze or
you know it could be a different order
so in this case because the order is
important we want to use the
permutations and we're going to say out
of 20 people how many ways are there to
pick three of them where that order is
important and so using our formula here
this is going to be 20 factorial Over N
minus r so 20 minus 3 is 17 factorial 20
factorial is 20 times 19 times 18 times
17 all the way down to one 17 factorial
is also 17 times 16 times 15 all the way
down to one so you can see that the 1716
all the way down to 1 are going to
cancel and we're just left with 20 times
19 times 18. now there's something
called the multiplication counting
principle or the fundamental counting
principle and what you do is you say how
many choices are there for like a first
place finisher there's 20 ways that
somebody could finish first once that
person finishes first how many different
people could finish for the second metal
that would be 19 and once those two
people finish how many ways are there
for a third place finisher 18. so you
can use this fundamental counting
principle or you can use this NPR
formula for this example so let's
multiply that out and see what that
comes out to
okay this is coming out to six thousand
840 different ways to award those three
metals okay if you want to test yourself
on some of these problems go ahead and
pause the video and see if you can do
them on your own but let's dive into
number three it says if there are 15
people on your chess team how many ways
can you choose two co-captains so what
do you think about that one
well what's interesting is
do you think that the order is important
like if they pick Joe first and Sally
second or Sally first and Joe second
like does the order matter
well in this case because they're
co-captains it's not like the the bike
race one where like gold silver bronze
like you would get a different metal in
this case they're co-capped and so it
doesn't matter a and b b and a they both
made it into uh being co-captains the
order doesn't matter you want to use
combinations so here we're saying out of
15 chess members how many ways are there
of choosing two where the order doesn't
matter so using our formula here we've
got 15 factorial Over N minus r so 15
minus 2 is 13 factorial
2 factorial now again remember the two
factorial is dividing out a and b b and
a those are the same two people so if we
simplify this down you can do this by
hand 15 factorial is 15 times 14 times
13 all the way down to one okay which
you could just write this as 13
factorial that's going to cancel with
this 13
factorial 13 12 11 all the way down to
one and then 2 factorial is just 2 times
1. 14 divided by 2 we could reduce that
to 7 and 15 times 7 is 105 divided by 1
is just 105. so there's 105
different ways to choose those two
co-captains out of the 15 chess members
okay so for number four see if you can
do this one it says if a school board
has eight women and four men how many
ways can a committee be formed with
three members such that all three are
men or all three are women or two are
women and one's a man and at least one
is a woman so we've got a multi apart
question here
now when you see the word committee is
very similar to what we did with the
co-captain so the order it's not
important right because it's not like
there's a president vice president
secretary treasurer like that the order
is not important when it's a committee
they're just all together
so it says all three are men so we know
that there's four men
and the order doesn't matter so we're
seeing out of four how many ways are
there of choosing three so we would say
4c3 now on your calculator there should
be a combination button also underneath
that probability menu so I'm going to do
that on the calculator I'm also going to
show you how to do it by hand in case
you can't use a calculator this is
coming out to four so let's just write
that here now for C3 using our formula
this is going to be 4 factorial
over four minus three see n minus r
which is one factorial
and R factorial which is 3 factorial
now 4 factorial is 4 times 3 times 2
times 1 1 times 3 factorial is just 3
factorial so that's three times two
times one
and you can see that's how we're getting
4.
so let's go to number a letter B here
all three are women well we know there's
eight women and we want to find out how
many ways of choosing three women out of
those eight where the order is not
important so it's a combination
so same idea we're going to do 8
factorial over eight minus three is five
factorial three factorial if you
simplify that down let's see what we get
and for letter C the two are women and
one's a man so this one's a little bit
different because out of the eight women
we're saying how many ways are there to
choose two
times out of the four men how many ways
they're of choosing one now you'll
notice the eight and the four add up to
12 the 12 people on the board and the
two and the one out to three members on
the committee and we're making use of
that fundamental County principle we're
saying how many ways are there to choose
the women how many ways are there to
choose the one man and we're multiplying
them together to get the total possible
outcomes so let's see what this comes
out to so eight combination two
is 28
and 4 combination one is four
and if we multiply those together
we get 112 So 112 outcomes there and for
the last one this one's a little bit
different at least one is a woman so
that means one could be a woman two
could be two women on the committee or
all three women could be on the
committee so when you see at least one
there's a little bit of a trick here
that you can do you can take the total
number of ways
of choosing three members okay out of
the 12 members minus
that none are women okay so at least one
is the total minus none and that'll give
you one or two or three women on the
committee so the total would be 12 c 3
out of 12 members how many ways are
there to choose a committee of three
members
minus none are women now none are women
that was like saying that all three of
them were men which there was four ways
there and so let's see what the 12
combination three is
that's 220 minus 4 is
216 ways that there could be at least
one women one woman on this committee
okay for number five we're going to be
dealing with some standard uh deck of
playing cards and you might be saying
Mario I'm not a card player don't worry
I'm not a card player either but the
thing you want to remember and you might
want to write this down is what is the
breakdown of a standard 52 card deck
well the 52 cards half are red and half
are black so 26 red 26 black of the red
cards they're divided up into what we
call suits so there's 13 hearts and 13
diamonds those are red okay whereas over
here there's 13 Spades and 13 clubs
those are black so half red half black
four suits and then underneath each suit
you've got a face card a king queen and
Jake Jack they have a face on it king
queen Jack and that's in each of the
suits and then there's a numbered cards
in each suit so there's uh two of Hearts
three of Hearts all the way through ten
of Hearts same thing with the diamonds
two through ten those are the numbered
cards and then you've got an ace in each
suit so an ace of hearts Ace of Diamond
Ace of Spades Ace of clubs so that's the
the breakdown so let's see if we can do
some problems here so it says how many
ways are there of being dealt a five
card hand out of a standard 52 card deck
if all cards are numbered
so what you would do is you'd say well
hmm how many numbered cards are there
well it looks like there's two through
ten that's nine nine nine nine times
four is 36 so there's 36 cards in the
deck that have a number on it and we
want to know how many ways they're being
dealt um five of those cards
okay so your Delta hand and so that
would be out of 36 how many ways are
there of choosing
five out of that 36 okay the numbered
cards now we're using combinations
because the order doesn't matter when
you're dealt those cards when you're in
your hand you can rearrange them so it
doesn't matter which card you're given
first second third because you can
rearrange them so it's the same five
cards so let's go ahead and figure out
what that is 36 combination five let's
see what that is
it looks like we're about okay 376
thousand
uh 992 different ways to be dealt all
numbered cards okay for letter B it
contains exactly one ace so five card
hand
okay and it contains exactly one ace
well let's see there's four aces so out
of the Four Aces how many ways are there
of being adult one of those four
times out of the 48 remaining cards that
are not Aces see 48 and 4 adds up to 52.
how many ways are there of being dealt
four of those cards out of the 48. so
just remember the first number is like
how many you're dealing with in that
group 48 non-aces and the second number
is how many we want out of that 48 okay
and we're using combination C because
the order doesn't matter so let's go
ahead and do this on the calculator 4c1
is Just 4 4 48 C4
is
580 and if we multiply that by 4 okay
we're getting 778
320 so 778 320 different ways of getting
a five card hand that contains exactly
one ace now what happens if you want no
Aces how many ways are there to be dealt
a five card hand and there's no aces in
that five card hand well because we said
there's four aces that means there's 48
cards that are not Aces and we want to
see how many ways they're getting five
out of that 48 so 48 combination five
okay and that comes out to
thank you
one million seven hundred thousand okay
and then for letter D all our diamonds
or all our clubs now in math let's talk
about this for a second or means Union
it means like combined it means both but
you don't want to double count so if
you're familiar with Venn diagrams
remember your Venn diagrams see here's
the diamonds here's the clubs or means
both combined together now if there were
overlapping like if there was some dimes
there were clubs and some clubs that
were also diamonds we'd have to double
count uh the ones we'd have to subtract
off the double counted ones we don't
want to double count but in this case
these are what they call mutually
exclusive or non-overlapping and so what
we can do is we can just add the number
of diamonds or the number of ways to get
five Diamonds the number of ways to get
five clubs so how many diamonds are
there there's 13 diamonds so out of the
13 Diamond cards how many ways are there
of choosing five of those where the
order doesn't matter plus out of the 13
clubs
how many ways are there of choosing five
of those so let's see what that comes
out to
this is
1287 Plus 1287.
which is
2574 ways of being dealt five diamonds
or five clubs okay so for letter e now
what is the probability of being dealt
all face cards okay now notice we're
dealing with probability probability is
the number of successful outcomes or
what we want divided by the total
possible outcomes
so being dealt all face cards so face
cards we can see that there's 12 face
cards
so out of 12 face cards how many ways
are there of getting five out of that 12
where the order doesn't matter divided
by the total ways of being dealt five
cards out of the 52 card deck see
probability again it's what you want out
of the total okay so in this case let's
see what this comes out to so 12
combination five
is 792 ways of being Delta all face
cards and 52
combination five is a big number two
five oops two five nine
eight nine six zero and you might be
able to reduce this down here I'll see
if it reduces down a little bit
uh let's see does that reduce my
calculator is not reducing it but you
could reduce it because see how they're
both even you can divide by two you can
also write it as a decimal approximation
you could even convert it to a percent
but that's really the percent chance
probability is more like a fraction or a
decimal not a percent okay and then the
last one letter F what is the
probability of being Delta at least one
face card so at least now again we're
dealing with probability and we did a
similar problem where we said at at
least one woman remember in that
committee but with probability
the total
is a hundred percent right that's that's
everything that could happen and 100
written it just as a number is the
number one one is like you know 100 so 1
minus
okay no face cards so we're going to do
the probability that you get no
face cards and uh let's see so no face
cards would be there's 12 face cards
which means that there's a 52 minus 12
49 face cards so that would be 40c 5.
so out of 40 non-face curves how many
ways are choosing five divided by how
many ways are there of getting
five face cards out of the 52 standard
deck here and we're going to take that
away from one so let's see what that
comes out to so 40
C 5.
okay divided by 52
C5
okay so this is basically I'm going to
round a little bit so this comes out to
about 0.25
so 1 minus 0.25 is going to be
0.75 so it's about a 75 percent chance
but the probability is 0.75 or 3 4
approximately and you got it okay let's
take a look at number six now it says
how many diagonals can be drawn in a
decagon so remember a decagon it's a
polygon with 10 sides and what exactly
is a diagonal well let's do a simpler
example and this is a good technique
sometimes if you ever have a difficult
problem try to do a simpler one and then
kind of extrapolate out and you can
solve a more challenging ones that way a
diagonal it connects two non-consecutive
vertices the vertices are the points
here on our polygon so for example this
would not be a diagonal but this would
be a diagonal this would be diagonal
this would not be a diagonal so what's
interesting here is
you can see you're connecting up two
points in the polygon right and there's
in this case there's five points total
and there's a similar problem that I
think I've done before in another video
where it's like you're at a party and
it's like how many different ways can
you know everyone shake hands with every
other person right so when you're
shaking hands like
there's two people are involved in that
handshake right and the order doesn't
matter if a shakes a person B's hand or
B shakespe person's a hand right that's
the same one handshake you don't want to
double count it so you're going to want
to use combinations because order
doesn't matter this vertices and this
vertices or this one and this one the
order doesn't matter but you're pairing
up two vertices out of the
okay in this case it's a decagon so 10
so we're sending out a 10 vertices how
many ways are there to choose two to
make a line segment between the two of
them that's a diagonal
but what's interesting about this is we
don't want to count the sides of the
polygon because those are not diagonals
so this is a segment but we want to
subtract that off so in a decagon
there's 10 sides we're going to subtract
off the the 10 side so let's see what
that comes out to so 10c2
is 45 minus 10 would be 35 diagonals now
you could try to draw but again that
takes a little bit more time so that's
why start with a simple example and then
you can apply that to a more challenging
problem let's look at number seven now
it says how many four digit numbers are
less than seven thousand with no zeros
and no ones
okay that's an interesting question so a
four digit number let's diagram this out
one two three four digits right
and you want it to be less than seven
thousand so less than seven thousand
means that this has to be well it can't
be zero because if the first digit was
Zero then it's only a three digit number
right can't be zero
can't be eight or nine because then that
would be like eight thousand nine
thousand can't even be seven because we
want it to be less than seven thousand
so basically that leaves us with one two
three four five
or six so there's basically uh six
choices for this number but we don't
want any zeros in one so that so one is
out so that means there's only five
possibilities for this first
a digit
okay times how many possibilities are
there for the second digit Well normally
there would be uh ten possibilities zero
one two three four five six seven eight
nine right zero through nine is ten
digits but we don't want any zeros so we
don't want any ones so ten minus two
would be eight
heat possibilities for the third digit
and eight possibilities for the fourth
digit and if we multiply those together
using that fundament fundamental County
principle or that multiplication
counting principle what does that come
out to let's see
uh
2560 numbers
are less than seven thousand with no
zeros and no ones so a lot faster than
having to actually try to write them
down and count all the possibilities
okay let's try number eight now so it
says how many different salads can be
made at a salad bar with 20 different
items
okay this is an interesting question so
just asking how many difference you walk
into the salad bar you say how many
different cells are possible
well it doesn't say like you're making a
salad with five ingredients or seven
ingredients or three ingredients it just
says how many different cells can be
made so one way to think about it is
it's kind of like a yes or no question
you walk up to the uh olives yes or no
right so basically there's there's two
choices then you go to the next item you
say do I want uh Tomatoes yes or no okay
and so basically because there's 20
items and there's two choices for each
item it's going to be 2 times 2 times 2
times 2 times 20 times that's 2 to the
20th power now
what happens if you said no I don't want
Tomatoes no I don't want lettuce no I
don't want this now okay you say no to
everything well then you really wouldn't
have a salad at all so that particular
outcome we're going to say that's no Sal
we're going to subtract that one off
okay so we could argue that that's
technically not a salad at all so let's
see what this comes out to so 2 to the
20th
okay minus one so this is
[Music]
1048575 so about a million different
cells that you could create
now again you know sometimes I know
students struggle with this permutations
combinations probability but if you can
understand these basic problems that
we're going through you can apply them
to other problems like say for example
it was like a true and false test how
many ways could you answer this true and
false test you wouldn't subtract one but
you would say oh there's 20 questions I
could pick true or false for the first
question true or false the second
question has two times two times two two
to the 20th so I hope this is
encouraging to you
um to try to apply this to other
problems so for number nine it says in a
warehouse
containing 12 items where four are
defective like broken right okay they're
bad what is the probability that you
receive a shipment of five items where
two are defective or bad so if there's
12 items total that means there's eight
good and four bad right and you're
receiving a shipment okay of five items
and it wants to know what is the
probability okay remember that's the
number of successes over the total
possible and what we're looking for is
that two are defective
okay so let's think about it so turret
effective so out of the four defective
items at this Warehouse how many ways
are there to get two now we're using
combinations because it doesn't matter
the order we're assuming these are all
the same kind of widget whatever that is
okay and then out of the eight good ones
how many ways are the uh to receive
three of the good ones out of the eight
good ones
that's going to give us the total number
of successes when I say success it's
like what you what you're looking for
what you want divided by the total
possible ways of receiving five items
from this Warehouse that has 12 of these
items okay so this is the total possible
so let's see what that comes out to so
we have
for
okay
uh huh
do this on the calculator
okay so this is coming out to
336 divided by
which is about
0.42 so it's about a 42 percent chance
that you would receive
too defective and three good for number
10 we have if a person's free throw
percentage is 70 percent what is the
probability of getting exactly four out
of five free throws so the percentage of
scoring is 70 percent that's a 0.70 and
what we're going to do is let's talk
about this
binomial probability so binomial means
like bias two so there's two
possibilities either you make the free
throw or you miss their free throw so
it's like win or lose succeed or fail
there's only two options right and so
the probability okay when it's a
binomial like this you take a number of
Trials
okay and the number of successes out of
that number of Trials the probability of
success the number of those successes
one minus the probability of success
which gives us our probability of
failure and the number of those failures
so the way we would set this one up is
we'd say there's five shots that you're
taking that's the five trials and we're
looking to get exactly four free throws
four successes the probability of making
the free throw is 70 or 0.7 0.70 we want
four of those and the probability of
missing is thirty percent and we want
one of those so let's see what that
comes out to uh 5c4
Okay add times point seven to the fourth
highest point three to the first okay so
this is coming out to 0.3 approximately
uh 36 percent or we just say as a
probability approximately 0.36
so that's binomial probability when
there's only two possible outcomes
okay now for number 11 I mean success or
failure right win or lose for number 11
what is the probability of picking a
face card or
a black card out of a deck of cards now
here we're talking about about
probability and we talked about the
breakdown of face cards or on face cards
but uh a deck of cards earlier remember
when it's probability it's going to be a
fraction out of the total so out of the
52 cards total or saying how many ways
are there to choose one
okay but we're saying that it's a a face
card or a black card now there's 12 face
cards we say how many ways are there to
choose one face card
plus how many uh black cards are there
there's 26 black cards because half our
black half are red choose one of those
but you see there's an overlap here some
of the face cards are black which means
that we're going to have to subtract off
the ones that were double counting that
are we counted in this group and this
group so that's going to be minus this
six
clubs and Spades face cards choose one
okay so let's see what this comes out to
so this would be uh let's see this is 12
choose one which is a 12 26 choose one
is 26 so that's 38 minus 60s ones is six
so that's 32 over 52.
which is uh let's see if we reduce that
down 4 goes in here eight times and four
goes in here 13 times so it'd be an 8
out of 13
probability which we can get that as a
decimal it's approximately uh
0.62 okay before we do these last four
word problems I wanted to let you know
about an algebra one and an Algebra 2
video course that I have for sale you
can check those out down in the
description the algebra 2 is also
suitable for like a college algebra
class so check out those videos where I
take you step by step through a typical
algebra one or Algebra 2 curriculum and
if you just like to support the videos
that I'm putting up here on my Mario's
math tutoring YouTube channel you like
the way I explain things you want to
help me to keep this going consider
supporting the channel as a channel
member so you can join the channel for a
few dollars a month and I really
appreciate that let's dive into the last
few examples so for number 12 it says a
contains three red marbles four blue
marbles and five yellow marbles what is
the probability of choosing two yellow
marbles without replacement so this is
important without replacement and
there's a couple different ways to do
this problem one way to do it remember
how we said probability is what you want
out of the total in this case we want
two yellow marbles so when we reach into
this bag
there's five yellow right and there's 12
total marbles so the probability of
getting a yellow would be five chances
of success out of 12 possible marbles
that you could pick once you pick that
first yellow marble when you go to reach
for the second yellow marble there's
only going to be four chances of success
out of 11 because there's one less
marble in the bag total so when we
multiply these together you can see
we're going to get uh 20 over a hundred
and thirty two
which we could reduce this down let's
see what was that reduced down
to um
5 30 thirds okay the other way to do it
is use the combinations you could say
out of five yellow how many ways are
there to choose two
and the total possible way of choosing
two marbles out of 12 you're going to
get the same answer 5 out of 33.
so for number 13 let's look at this one
a couple plans to have five children
assuming that boys and girls are equally
likely find the probability that the
couple will have at least one girl so
we've seen this a lot in this particular
video at least right
so at least when it comes out to
probability 100 is the total which is
like the number one minus the
probability that they have no girls
okay so one minus probably of no girls
means it's one or more so one two three
four or all five now no girls is another
way of saying all boys right and what's
the probability the first one's a boy
it's one chance out of two what's
probably the second one's a boy one out
of two one out of two one out of two one
half one half one half so that's really
one half to the fifth power okay and we
want one minus that so one half to the
fifth is one over thirty-two one is like
32 over 32 minus one would be 31 over
thirty two so that would be your
probability of having at least one girl
okay before we do these last two
problems I'll indicate at the end of
this video uh another video that you can
click on if you want more practice and
and more problems to kind of work on a
video that I did similar to this
different problems obviously uh for more
practice but let's do these last two
problems it says you forget the order of
the five number combination to your safe
if you remember the middle number what
is the probability that you guessed the
correct order of the remaining digits on
the first attempt
okay that's interesting so what do you
think for that one
well let's kind of diagram this out so
you've got one two three four five uh
numbers now you know all five in the
numbers okay it's just that you forgot
the order of those five numbers well you
do remember what what the middle number
is so you know what this guy is right
right here so let's kind of X that one
off so really of these four digits that
you have in your head you just have to
remember what order to put them in right
so how many different ways could you
order these for remaining numbers okay
now the order is important right so we
could do this as a 4 factorial see
that's the number of ways of ordering
four items we could also do
4p4
4p4 is the same thing as 4 factorial and
the reason that is is because when you
do 4 minus 4 that 0 factorial and 0
factorial is one which is just going to
give you the numerator and factorial or
4 factorial or you can use the
fundamental counting principle you can
say there's four choices for which one I
try for the first number then 3 8 for
that next number two for this one and
then one for this one so that comes out
to 4 times 3 times 2 times 1 which is 24
but only one of those is correct right
so the probability you think of
probability it's the number of
successful outcomes over the total
possible so this is going to be 1 over 4
factorial which is 24 so a 1 24 chance
it's going to work before the alarm goes
off right okay so number 15 a math
professor assigns 30 probability
problems from the textbook for an
upcoming test which will have 15 of
these problems on it
I should have written these exact
problems on it if you only know how to
solve 20 of them okay 20 of the 30. what
is the problem that you get all the 15
problems correct on this test
so what do you think about that one so
it's definitely a probability problem
so we want to think about this as number
of successes over the total possible
and you know 20 of these problems right
so if your teacher
by some crazy chance
they give you 15 of those problems from
the book out of the 20 that you know how
many ways could that happen right again
the order doesn't matter either they're
just going to be on the same test
doesn't matter what order they're in so
that's why we're using combinations but
the total ways that uh
a professor math professor could choose
15 problems out of 30. how many ways
could that occur so these are the number
of successes over the total possible
let's do this on the calculator let's
see what we got here so 20
combination 15.
okay so this is like 15
504 ways
and 30 combination
is like a big number
and if we divide those
okay we're getting basically uh point
zero zero zero one okay so so it's a
very slim chance that you're going to
get them all right you might get
you know some of them right but the
chances they pick exactly the ones that
you studied and knew this would be how
you do that one so great job if you're
able to follow this video if you want
more examples go ahead and follow me
over to that previous video that I did
talking about permutations combinations
and probability I'll see you over in
that video